wanda and um visions journey and the
other characters
get more complex as as we move forward
um and there's there there are more
surprises
and um and more conflict to see
maria died three years ago
no no no which was two years after you
after our wife after i
what after you disappeared
i'm very grateful for episode 4 because
i feel like we have a little bit to talk
about now so
first of all we see the unblippening and
in far from home it was like
kind of used as this comedic effect kind
of thing but here we feel this like
seriousness and gravity of it
so what was the conversation around it
and using this as
monica's intro yeah i mean
um the unblippeting that's pretty good i
have not
heard that at all and i will be taking
that with me um
yeah well we so our priority was
introducing monica that was always
what we wanted to do um well at the at
the top of the show
and and then our and second to that our
priority was
was sort of the like the 180
of this this episode being entirely
separate from what we've seen
um but we also wanted to answer the
question of where
are we in the mcu timeline
um and so this idea seemed to satisfy
all of those things all at once um it
you know it's set up tonally
that we're in a you know we're in
a dramatic scenario a more grounded
scenario
we learn so much about monica um and and
what she's dealing with um in that cold
open um and then of course like
it's always exciting to be able to um
uh to approach mcu cannon and shed new
light on it
definitely and we kind of find out in
this moment that
maria passed away during all of this so
which can't have been an easy choice to
kind of like how you deliver that so
what was the conversation surrounding
that and how that news should be
addressed
yeah it was a big decision we had a lot
of conversations um
and she is such uh maria
and lashana the actor um were
so important in captain marvel and um
such a tremendous character
um and it it it was not
we did not um make that decision lightly
um but um we felt that it really
worked for um for monica's character
um and what it meant for her um and we
also you know really loved
the idea that maria had um built sword
from the ground up
so there's a lot of names thrown at us
in this episode in episode four and
i know a lot of fans were doing what i
was doing we were pausing we were
googling we were like who's related
to who what's going on and a lot of
people were linking
tyler hayward's name to an agent of
shield character
are we on the right track could they be
related it's unintentional
i can't as much as i love the theories i
i am not allowed to speak to any of them
really
i'm i'm sure i'm just you know i gotta
hound you with questions
you have to answer i have to ask there
are so many theories have you seen one
that's
getting close or scarily accurate yet um
they're i mean i think that i've seen a
lot that
analyze the work in a way that is
gratifying to us as the creatives you
know people who
um you know are taking note to
to of of our priorities you know with
like
you know darcy lewis it was really
important to us that that
we show that eight years is a long time
and she
has accomplished a lot and is a
different person um
and so you know the fans enjoying her
moment where she asserted herself as a
doctor
yeah it's a teeny tiny moment but it was
important to me
and and um to my partners on this
literally my next question is just
seeing
darcy's journey since the dark world and
knowing that she was like a poli sci
major
and now she's an astrophysicist so how
did you wrap your head around where
she's been
well so yeah we we actually did a lot
of um brainstorming about where the heck
um
darcy's been and what she's been up to
and there there were a lot of ideas that
didn't make it um into the show but i i
feel um it helped us in
in in creating this this newer version
of her um
but you know because it had been eight
years we were like that's time
enough for a phd and she you know
was integral to everything that um you
know dr jane foster had done
so it just we liked the idea that she
could
still be still have that same sardonic
hilarious voice um but really
have become more serious and and have
a reputation inside of the world of the
mcu as
being an expert which like that just
sounded so great to us
is there anything that didn't make it
that you were just referencing that you
can reveal
i don't think i can maybe on the other
side i wish i could i would like i wish
i could spend like a whole day just
talking about
our darcy lewis ideas and our jimmy moo
ideas we
they they were um just really really
great sources of joy for us when we were
developing the series uh fans were
loving that jimmy wu
learned his close-up magic trick then he
wanted to learn how fun was that
to add in and how did randall react to
that little bit of character development
oh he
loved it he thought that was great he
was practicing it like
it you know you you so many of these
characters
they appear fleetingly you know and
they're
and they they're little sort of details
about them and so you know
trying to carry a character forward you
want to be faithful right so you
you analyze all the little details but
it really it felt so special
um to have the fact that like he you
know loved
magic and then you know the magic show
in
in episode two like it all sort of like
came together in this really beautiful
way
it was a very early idea i i think it
was i think it was one of my writers
peter cameron who came up with the idea
i think it was i hope i'm not miss
voting he's wonderful regardless
um but um that the idea that he
yeah had finally gotten really good at
it is so crazy
it's it's like my favorite type of
easter eggs too because i think a lot of
fans are so ready for kind of certain
things to happen
and then when something subtle like that
happens we're like oh my god that's
right he wanted to learn that trick
like uh it's just so satisfying well i
think also
you know a lot of us in the room like
and just humans in general we all kind
of
know what it's like to feel like a like
a supporting player to feel like a
background character
and and so the idea that someone is
really watching you and is paying
attention to you
and that sees you as like a full human
being um
i think it's i think it's born of that
impulse that we wanted to
to you know give give him the good stuff
yeah and
and randall's character kind of acts as
the audience like he's asking all the
exact same questions that we're asking
so i have to know
are we going to get all of these answers
by the end of the season
[Laughter]
we we will answer all the things that
need to be answered
um we yeah i mean truthfully randall
is the writers like that that that was
like us
writing on the on the whiteboard in the
writers room being like how do we make
sure
that this this mystery checks out that
the logic checks out that like all of
this
is working um so that
i'm i'm so pleased that that that that
white board is getting
like the shine that it's getting because
um
because there were there are so many
details that that didn't make it into
the show
um that were like you know the the
various pieces of our kind of like
larger world building
um but yeah there'll be answers don't
don't you okay okay
so this episode was starting to give me
the uneasy feelings about
wanda what can you tease about her arc
the rest of the season and how it's
going to tie into the greater mcu
picture
yeah so um next to nothing i can tell
you
um that both wanda and
um vision's journey and the other
characters get
more complex as as we move forward um
and there's
there there are more surprises and um
and more conflict to see don't worry
darling
i have everything under control
[Music]